grazie Caro Presidente thank you for
inviting the European Commission to the
inaugural session of your national
consultation and you're right in these
months we've worked very closely
together and this is how things should
always work Rome and Brussels together
for Italy and for Europe indeed today
Italy is getting back on its feet the
shopping windows on your city's main
streets are lightening up again the
factory gates are reopening cafes and
restaurants are once again filled with
the sound of chatter and the smell of
good food there is still so much to do
but this is already something that warms
our hearts Italy has been hit before
anyone else in Europe and you've been
hit the hardest thousands have died and
this is a void that no one can ever fill
and my thoughts are with the victims and
their families and also with the doctors
health care workers and every citizen
who's helped save lives and deliver
essential services Grazia Italia your
government has taken bold measures
asking people to stay home for long
weeks and month it required courage but
it worked and you led the way for other
member states you have also taken bold
measures to secure jobs protect
companies and limit the damage to the
Italian economy and after the deep fall
in the past month economic activity is
gradually rebounding yet we all
understand that the recovery will be a
generational challenge not only for
Italy but for Europe as a whole so today
I can say the spirit of our founders is
back
Europe is back leahrob said esta today
we know that we can only defeat this
crisis if we do it together
so solidarity is not just the most
ethical choice it is the only effective
way to deal with the crisis of this
magnitude and this is the core idea
behind next generation you our new
recovery plan that will sit on top of a
revamped long-term new budget this is
Europe's moment it is the moment to join
forces and react to the pandemics fall
out across all Member States it is the
moment to tackle divergences and dis
parent disparities among different parts
of Europe to leave no country and no
region behind and next generation EU is
an alliance between generations we the
European Union for the very first time
borrowing money from our children so our
investment today must deliver for our
children we shall not as sometimes our
member states did borrow from our
children just to spend the money today
today we invest for Europe's next
generation next generation you turns the
extraordinary challenge we face into an
opportunity as we tackle the current
crisis we are also shaping the Europe of
tomorrow a more competitive fair and
sustainable Europe a more green and
digital Europe and this means unlocking
massive public and private resources to
invest in digital technologies
infrastructure and innovation it also
means that no one must be left behind
solidarity cohesion and
virgins are crucial to succeed and as we
invest to shape the economy of the
future we must also work on ambitious
reforms to ensure that our investment
deliver on the citizens needs and
expectations reforms will lead to
recovery and reforms need your
leadership and your ownership
I believe that next generation EU is a
unique opportunity for Italy the
proposals by the Commission in
particular the recovery and resilience
facility and visit unprecedented support
for our member states including Italy so
next generation you can address
long-standing challenges affecting the
Italian economy and it will pave the way
for lasting economic recovery it is now
up to you to make it happen and I am
very glad that today you're bringing
together the public and the private
sector the entrepreneurs and the workers
organizations the future of any of our
countries can only be built together
listening to all voices and mobilizing
all the best energies and let me think
you gzip for the patient work that you
are doing in bringing your country
together and I'm so grateful for your
proposal of a strategic plan of reforms
for Italy's recovery we all know that
Italy's high level of public debt
exposes you to the markets changing
moods but with the right reforms Italy
can make the most out of next generation
you in your plan you mentioned the need
to reduce red tape to make the public
sector more efficient to ensure that
public works are shielded from organised
crime
the capacity and quality of Italy's
public administration will be essential
so that the new resources from next
generation you can be put to good use
the labor market presents challenges
female and youth employment is too low
and we all know that you cannot build a
successful economy without youth and
women Italy has indeed welcomed
enthusiastically the European Green Deal
which as you know is very close to my
heart we fully agree on the need to keep
investing in a more sustainable economy
but also on digitalization and
innovation as you just said in this twin
transition greener digital education and
skills will be crucial our education
systems and our research must also adapt
to changing times
your youth demand to be better prepared
on the most pressing issues of our times
and the young people are right Giuseppe
you have also mentioned a substantial
reform of your text system and a more
effective justice system and this is
crucial for Italy's businesses of all
sizes so gzip I couldn't agree more with
your words this is the time to raise our
heads and cast our eyes of to the future
that's what you've said and we shouldn't
just aim at restoring the status quo
this never works next generation EU is a
chance for Italy and Europe to decide
what our future should look like
throughout the years Italy has always
surprised the world
you have reached from the deepest crisis
you have preserved your identity and
your traditions while innovating and
reinventing yourself and thanks to this
Italy has today the second largest
industrial base of Europe all around the
world made in Italy means beauty and top
quality the decisions you take today
will shape the Italy of tomorrow and
this is the moment for you to develop
and implement an effective recovery plan
and the Commission will be there to
support you and accompany you through
reforms to recovery Europe needs a
strong Italy at its core one lavoro a
viva la ropa